I'm pleased to join be joined right now
by the chairman of vaynermedia also CEO
of Vayner Sports he has also been very
integral in getting the all in challenge
that so many of us have heard about so
many celebrities have gotten all in on
he's been very instrumental in getting
that off the ground he is our friend
Gary Vaynerchuk how are you Gary Vee I'm
extremely well thanks for having me on
you bet everybody well in your family in
your neck of the woods everybody knock
on wood okay yes knock on wood okay
thank you so much for asking
you bet of course how did the all-in
challenge come to be walk me through
this guy yeah Michael Rubin the founder
and chairman of fanatics which I'm sure
all the listeners are aware of since
that's where you buy your sports merch
came up with this idea was sitting
around wanted to give back
reached out his friend Alan Tisch they
went in a couple days in they said wait
a minute we need a lot more firepower
and reached out and I got excited about
it and we've been under a cocoon for the
last you know ten days it's been live
for about seven 1/2 days we've raised
16.1 million dollars amazing and we are
going to be feeding people through
putting all all proceeds feeding America
no Kid Hungry and so it's been
unbelievable like I don't know you know
it has gotten a lot of tension so I
think people have seen it but like golf
with you know Justin Timberlake and Bill
Murray at Pebble Beach you know you know
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman you know
going through and to your house and
doing a lemonade stand there's a stall
Soren's give me a one-day contract to be
a maverick and I'm here and putting you
in the game you know some Drake Allen
generous colors like crazy crazy crazy
stuff so super super duper exciting yeah
again places like feeding America Meals
on Wheels world central kitchen no Kid
Hungry just to name a few to combat food
insecurity and the neat thing about this
Gary that I love is obviously the the
famous people wanting to pitch in that
that that is a lot of pizzazz to it but
there's a and I know you're all about
this certainly with your empathy wines
there's a lot of positivity to this it's
it's it's all focusing on what we
do now and then focusing on what the
world will be when we're through all
this and the great stuff that people can
look forward to I love that part of it
Gary I think yeah I think so I think you
know you look for win-win situations
right and the access that these
individuals are giving and a lot of
these individuals have been doing a ton
of stuff behind the scenes and giving
already but now they're giving up you
know time and it's really significant
it's been really fun and the raffle
tickets attempt me up for 10 bucks you
could be flying on Drake's plane and go
into his concert hanging out with them
or being Leo DiCaprio his new movie with
a speaking role like it's pretty intense
stuff yeah again because this isn't just
an one of certainly linger on this a
little bit here is is it it's a raffle
right and then there's of course you can
bid as well so you have a chance to
auction some our auctions summer raffles
you know there's a lot of dynamics
honestly we're just trying to figure out
how to raise the most amount of dollars
so it you know Tom Brady's experience
right a gentleman I despise you know
this package right the court bid at
$775,000 this is you flying to Game one
he flies you in you you after the game
he goes out to dinner with you after his
first game as a buck and gives you the
cleats and the jersey that he wore if
you know that's hard to replicate that
is hard to replicate yeah I just love
your jets love man right there on your
sleeve let's call what it is as much as
the all-in challenge has been taking up
my time so we're around a couple hours
ago I'd switch completely let's get in
that Jets 11th on the clock they have
their choice of a left tackle or any of
the wide outs any of them which one do
you want the Jets to do Gary I mean
anybody would have a brain knows we're
going left tackle on that spot yeah
we've got two second-round picks this is
the greatest receiver draft ever maybe
obviously it all has to play out but the
talents enormous obviously I have a
sports representation business and my
brother was Boehner sports so I deeply
like I'm in love with this class not
only for its depth not only because we
need receivers and it's loaded but
because I've actually got to know
a lot of these characters through the
process it's a good group there's a
couple knuckleheads you know I'm not
gonna try to hurt somebody's draft stock
there then the team's already they do
their homework there's some knuckleheads
but this is a high quality class and so
frankly I'd like to move out of eleven
huh I think they're I think there's some
sneaky tackles up this is we don't wrap
this kid that I love them I think the
Austin Jackson kid
from USC is interesting he'll probably
be available late first round I I want
to jettison but you've done a lot of
holes we have a lot a lot of holes we
need a lot of talent oh yeah I mean
Daniel Jeremiah calls this a Noah's Ark
offseason for the Jets because they need
two of everything is what he said you
know and and it's time so much you can
do he didn't have that much money to do
much because we front-loaded so much a
contract so it's not just cash it's cap
and vice versa we'll be in a much better
spot next year because I think I rich I
think the Jets have a real GM I really
mean that and I'm very on the record you
know I I despised Mike McKagan I think
he's well put down in five years one of
the worst GM records you've ever seen
considering the money he went into and
the situation in every long-term
contract he signed whether it's Tremaine
or mo Wilkerson Meade he completely
misplayed it and so and the drafts have
been a struggle and oh by the way rich
just to remind you the New York Jets
needed a quarterback the year they took
Jamal atoms and Jamal Adams is an
extremely big-time player but just on
the record for everybody's listening
the Jets needed a quarterback Josh
McCown was a quarterback that going that
year who's one of the best humans but
was obviously late in his career and not
a Super Bowl caliber quarterback and we
took Jamal oh by the way we took another
safety in the second round and the and
we took Jamal and the next two
quarterbacks taken at seven and ten for
DeSean Jack was Shaun Watson and Patrick
Mahoney I know Gary I know it's just oh
my god you know we could go back all the
way to ken O'Brien over Dan Marino I
mean there's a history this sort of
thing we all wear the scars that said
though
Jamal Adams is a culture changer in that
locker room it's time
to sign him right like what's going on
with with him in them do you think Gary
um I think I think that Joe isn't forced
to sign him just yet Joe loves Jamal
he's on the record for that you know
like I think Joe had an off season to
attack I think Joe's got 40 holes he had
you know twenty three free agents going
into the season like had to nickel and
dime and take care of stuff and you know
I think rightfully I mean I balls my
friend right alone I'm a Jets fan right
he's got that time like I understand
like you know listen football players
I'm on the agent side football should
want to get signed as early as possible
but I hope everybody like let's get
let's get something completely out of
the way it's laughable how fans think
about this this is 100% business and oh
by the way 100% business from every side
you know like it's really easy for a
player after fact to say hometown
discount you mean there was no market
for you I mean come on let's let's
really get into this like nobody's in
the business of doing charity for each
other this is purely business just like
when you do business rich when I do
business there's all business it's all
business
and when you've still got two years on
your deal this is not the time to
negotiate when he's got a great leverage
in other places period yeah and we just
had on before Tom Curran from NBC Sports
Boston say that this this grant return
was totally orchestrated by team Gronk
to force this to happen by Unruh tiring
at the worst possible time for the
cash-strapped Patriots it and get him to
Tom so I mean I think I think that's
that's that's that speaks into what's
really going on there right I mean I
think you know all empires all evil
empires have to come to an end so you
know for one to do that one would argue
that they're not as in love with the
owner the coaches they all like to play
up there and so you know listen
unparalleled success will be very
difficult to replicate right Boston
Celtics type stuff like it was a great
run but like you know Tom not being in
New England's a nice starting point I
still think Belichick is an all-time
coach and I will never forget that Matt
Cassel year so I know exactly what that
looked like that 1105 team that didn't
make the playoffs so thank God because
who knows what they were
in there so it's gonna be interesting to
watch but you know we need to build
around our young quarterback that's what
I'm focused on we've got a long way to
go and this is an all time important
draft and I think we have an emotionally
intelligent and football man at the top
and I expect this to be a fundamentally
successful draft Gary Vaynerchuk here on
the Rich Eisen show five-time
best-selling author what swine tex.com
what's that
I thank you a man come on Gary Gary Gary
Gary there may be an iron-rich and Eisen
but I'm a team player
anybody who's listening right after you
buy wine wine text calm is a deal add a
texting platform so it's kind of like
the old Groupon or the LivingSocial when
you get a crazy deal $58 cabernet 14
bucks $28 Chardonnay you know $13 just
none you just reply with a 2 3 4 & 5 so
I know sports and wine go hand-in-hand I
know a lot of you are sitting at home
right now given the current situation so
if you're buying some those deal of day
email sites or services or apps highly
recommend you check out Wyant XCOM my
father sasha will be very I like it very
good and so your I guess the guy to
definitely ask about this when you're
when you're talking to people in your
world a business and obviously little
bit of sports do you think we're gonna
happen when do you think we get sports
back Gary I mean I know that that's the
million-dollar question and people who
are experts on health can't answer it
but I'm wondering what you're the
general senses later late July August I
mean I think I think we have to be
prepared for sports with no attendance I
think there's gonna be a phased attack
you know I think there's a substantial
chance that several weeks you know you
can see the NFL playing without crowds
mm-hmm I mean real lot real talk like
it's very strange to think about what
this might look like but definitely the
sports affected right now you know
hockey basketball baseball you know UFC
boxing like you may see a scenario where
we'll be watching sports without people
in attendance and oh by the way and oh
by the way the reality is is that we're
we're gonna go into an environment where
we're about to see ratings on this NFL
drop rich literally the entire country
is gonna look at your beautiful face
like I am you know I'm not watching this
last dance documentary because it might
expand them yes but I'm sure the ratings
on it are phenomenal and I'm sure it's a
nice show right but this NFL Draft like
when I tell you I can't wait to see the
ratings obviously there's multiple
networks and things that nature but I
mean everything I believe non NFL fans
are going to watch it because it's
something to live sports and I'm
genuinely excited about it yeah I meet
me - and I know you're zooming in to the
draft athan I think I'm for that I think
you're gonna be joy son on the draft if
aunt Gary correct I'll be there always
appreciative you want the jet to take I
I want I want the left tackle that's
remaining that's what I want you got to
protect the kid man
I mean you got to put it here's the
problem Gary is that you've gotta
evaluate him I know you're very high on
him and whenever I've met him he has you
at hello the minutes and Arnold opens
his mouth forget about this charisma
it's data-rich him in a clean pocket is
crazy data we got to protect them it's
his passing ratings his data is cleaning
when he has a clean pocket and let's not
kick twisted his offensive lines have
been very very difficult situations
he's been unbelievably good I know but
the problem is is he can't he hasn't
been able to stay healthy and that he
also doesn't have maybe the weaponry in
which to to actually evaluate him and
it's just freaking me out that the Jets
in this day and age you know it being a
sports fan and an agent from from all
angles here Gary you know you gotta win
the championship and the quarterbacks
first contract because he's gonna start
being worth 25 30 35 million bucks could
even go more north of that and and and
he may not have to even play in a
playoff game in order to demand that
sort of salary so that's the concern is
I don't know if they're gonna have the
time to actually evaluate that on him I
just don't know if they're gonna have
that and that's the thing that you know
taking a left tackle is very difficult
to do certainly when you may have every
single possible receiver playmaker
that's sitting out there no no no it's
not it's not
impossible rich go on youtube and watch
when the jet strapped did D'Brickashaw
Ferguson ESPN zooms into the crowd and
you'll see a young pointing to my head
saying it's a smart pick and everybody
wanted us to take matte liners and I
wanted to brick a Shaw and then I went
wild when we took Nick Mangold I you
know I understand that fans get excited
about highlight reels
there is no highlight reels if you don't
have time to make it I am thrilled to go
left tackle here I will be upset if we
go wide receiver here because I know how
deep the receiver classes and you
there's gonna be a full round receiver
who's gonna be an all-pro strip trap
that's it this is all right before you
leave you want to pound the table for
your boy Montez nobody's talking about
him go for it do you like them I'm glad
that's what you decided to bring up
bring up every one of your clients I
mean but I get it Barney who is gonna be
the first off the board he's gonna be a
sneaky corner folks out of UCLA Booker
yeah listen I think Montez is going to
find himself on an NFL roster I think he
had a really strong combine showed his
athleticism he's a really great kid
which I think genuinely matters I think
a lot of these quarterbacks are lost at
hello to your point by the way and I
think that he's got all the raw talents
in Colorado you know he he made some
decisions that put up some picks and I
think that puts him in the police that
he's at and so I think he's a mid-late
kind of guy and I think it's gonna be
you've got a cut listen he's been on
Hugh calls all week so clearly there's
interest in him so that's good to think
right so I'm excited about Stephen and I
I love the way he ran his 40 and I
course you know 15-year old Gary lost
his mind when he heard Rich Eisen his
name-o McDonald and Steve going back to
back there so I appreciate your your
friend and and a colleague and and all
that stuff man I appreciate every time
you support this show or call in in any
way shape or form it's always a great
it's always a blast Gary always keep
doing that can't we can watch it right
back at you that's a Gary Vee at Gary
Vee on Twitter Instagram everybody's
following him you should too CEO and
co-founder of vaynermedia again that the
beautiful
all in challenge that's going on hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here